and those two videos were actually just
appetizers it was funny that cat told
about her weekend plans with the
Vietnamese food we've got a bunch of
Asian food has talked about two weeks
ago or you got any bam Chi or what is it
I know I know Brendon is absolutely
starving so we can't tell you what it is
you have to call me out like we're gonna
run into fat-ass can't wait we're gonna
my lovely girlfriend Jules is gonna
bring it in I'm gonna helmet Jules girl
and we've got four different types of
Asian food and you guys just tell us
what you think hopefully we can keep the
banter up and the chewing out of the
mics and tell us what you like the best
will cut it up if it's too slow for
video okay tell you what I wish we had
that Diet Coke what is this already
Asian or not yeah I can't go to Subway
and try to claim with the Asian cuz its
teriyaki on it this is straight out of
Westminster just where cat went actually
I went down there last night what did
you have a cat what was your order I had
low on them family um do don't want that
BAM YUM BAM yo is that a real thing are
you just saying I have a plate of it boy
that BAM YUM I want BAM you more mm-hmm
what is this Bank is this cheap sashimi
some of us look a little suspect up is
it all from the same place no oh there
are four different types of Asian foods
a bit a postman before I think you guys
should take a guess at what uh what
ethnicity each food is oh wow that's
kimchi right don't you yeah you can't
eat dudes I don't cheat when I'm right
here some kind of freak boy freak
someone gets like up that sausage and
whatever this is it looks like thing a
little exotic oh yeah that's a young
loud boy sausage can always be
questionable I think yeah
I'm always super septal sausage unless
it's coming from LaCie smoking Lacey's
yeah smoking Lacey's I go really wash
this down with that Diet Coke real okay
try the other ones too
I'm okay I'm just teriyaki whatever is
oh yeah I've got a little bit of earlobe
in a nothing case I get it heard
something boy good okay Jen if you were
to pick a Korean food what would you
what would be the dish I mean how it's
always stick by cream by the original
Korean barbecue you know yeah I'm scared
to try some of it yeah the sandwich to
me looks the most like home like you
said sub no like it looks like Subway
you couldn't but it's not that's
authentic you went to a real creator
Asian place for this stuff all four of
them
Wow mm-hmm that looks good I can't
emphasize enough if I had a diet coke
I'll just text to him I have to fire
doing something hey that sound is nice
Wow no NIC is there extra mm oh yeah I
believe and that might be bull meat this
might be straight bull meat this might
be that Wuhan finest here Oh
oh yeah this had a little bit of good in
it yeah that might be a bat way over
there oh yeah dude that might be that
Heath Ledger bra you feel me
I feel you this thing looks like it has
been she's deceased baby I'm a
sweet-and-sour sauce when I see it you
feel me oh you can always dump enough
that on there oh yeah
just got this at lamb Jim this is lamb
based I think there's a jam isn't it
yeah it's more of a jam than a
sweet-and-sour sauce it tastes like
somebody freaking
it pulled it off the bottom of a puddle
right here man
Wow yeah we get an exotic okay mmm let's
have street shark right here baby mm-hmm
oh wow there's a thing if I think about
something enough
I'll start gagging if I don't know what
it is I said oh my food baby that
sausage has a weird vibe to it yeah
no sausage has that are micro be like
Roby a break or something my house like
a real yep Oh God god bless you dude
dang we got a dark bag of beverages here
yeah you guys want one I'm good just
check out that pet owner sausages you
have the weird vibe on it it tastes like
somebody wrote if found on the collar
that kidnap here we got something real
wild here do ya see I don't you try it
first
I'm gonna go and dive back into this
mm-hmm me wits a contest Brendon what's
the contest to wit to name which
countries are from oh wow
Brendan is just looking for nourishment
oh dude I'm sure I get the calories this
is game Han baby oh yeah ain't no hands
in Asia brother oh yeah
do you already know what they all are I
kind of a feeling yeah this is a rotator
cuff out of song I can feel this thing's
turned the doorknob or something a
little bit you know yeah this thing's
apparently has some sort of weird gravy
on you taste the tour that thick gravy
no I don't know man oh yeah dude this is
definitely hmm it's like the rotator
cuff my damn Falcon right here ooh
Thanksgiving hitter you taste it yeah I
don't taste like anything's given I've
ever had yeah boy get in there Wow ma'am
I encourage all the audio listeners to
go check out the YouTube this is gonna
be much more enjoyable these are really
and these are different you do you know
what all these dishes are cat or now I
can guess I think I do and this is lamb
I think so there's a good bit of lamb up
anymore that teriyaki beef you let me
know there's a good bit of adult lamb we
got any beef wore out of beep whatever
mm-hm
exotic zebra that was listen let's take
some guesses what what countries do we
think those are from we got four Asian
countries do we get to know the
countries or we just get I say just
guess okay we can we can air it if you
need mm-hmm okay
hmm I would like to pick her you pick a
country first all right I'll go with Wow
good I'll say Kat and chin are both
represented okay I'm gonna go with this
dish here with the kimchi is a Korean
Korean is that the soft it's off
wait do we name it and they tell us or
how do we do this both of you guests and
then we'll tell you after okay that's
better
I'm go this this was this is Korean
uh-huh this little batwing here with the
gravy is Chinese oh that's that space
lamb baby that's that dark arts bird
also known as a bat oh that's it that's
it that's a bat that is the biggest
matter of every song that bat has a
little bit of beagle in the sausage I
must say Philippines so glasses [ __ ] go
on like sausage I'm gonna say it
Philippi
hold on
and then the sandwich is from Taiwan or
just Chinese people who give a [ __ ]
until they are this is from Taiwanese
hmm
and then also rank them what was your
favorite oh the green dish number one
the gravy batwing dead last the sandwich
from Taiwan number two the sausage from
the Philippines
number three and deal okay I'm a roll
with this I'm gonna roll with right here
about Korean right they're a little
Korean Christmas a little Korean
Christmas breakfast right there fam baby
sit right here I'm gonna go with the and
that's gonna be the enemies right there
okay right out the gate now here is
where it gets a little bit oh that's
where it gets a little bit more urban
you know what I'm saying yeah you can
straight you can't even troll this plate
man I'm gonna say right here we're
getting into that kind of darker Asian
I'm gonna go with um the Pinoy baby I'll
go with Filipinos right there cuz they
out there they got a little hold out
there with them that's the like rice
this right here dude this seem like that
duck out of uh that Christmas duck out
of that movie yes duck bro the duck has
uh this that duck Christmas ducks they
shoot the boy and I you know I think
it's like Chicago or something I don't
know I keep referencing Christmas the
Terre argues Christmas dude in that's
Christmas dude it's Sam Christmas I got
four plates of food in front of me man
this is Christmas so this one let me do
you rather have ideas huh right now
today in concrete yeah me too that's I
said Taiwan oh no no I forgot about this
one this one I'm gonna go with I guess
I'll go with Chinese so Korean
Vietnamese Filipino Chinese I think we
start the same thing yeah yeah I know
you go
we got something do know is this Chinese
all day Brendan said Korean was Korean
and that was his favorite nailed it he
said uh what what good you got this
wrong we'll see ya he said the Filipino
food that he ranked last was Chinese
that's chicken adobo yep
news to me the one that you said was
Philippines the sausage that is Thai
sausage oh I know I was part of Asia
yeah
no we're going that big I don't know
we're going that global with it that's a
you wish you don't well then with them
Russian foods considered a just two then
you know I'm saying done no Russia's
Asia truth and finally the Vietnamese
Brendon wet with Taiwanese which is not
represented on our slick though I'll
respect that pic now hmm Co got
Vietnamese correct and that's all that's
all he got right there is no food from
Christmas Story Christmas Korean though
Oh Oh a nice Christmas Korean breakfast
right yeah yeah so he said the first
once you got to this is Korean yeah okay
so I got Korean and Vietnamese but I did
not get what is this tie tie tie tie
sausage no one got tired mmm and it's
Filipino yeah we just switched it up a
Filipinos to Pinot Grigio which is a
wine
good idea bro to the barbecue yeah you
know greasy I'm coach I'm the lounge
you've obviously opened up as soon as
this be easy
[Laughter]
[Music]